so i came up to la
for dance and i was dancing
um
and
then i moved to germany to be in this
girl group and
so i was like kind of doing the backup
dancing thing and then i was uh
in the forefront and then i came back
and because i was like
and the the girls still wanted to do
like the singing group but i'm like like
this is not isn't singing is not my gift
to share with the world
um but you could dance and i could dance
um and
and i went on tour with avril lavigne
and like how did that happen how do you
just tour with avril lavigne do you
audition for avril lavigne
so how many girls auditioned for an
avril lavigne video
or tour tour tours are always like
tours are big ones for dancers so you
get you get a lot of people um
i don't i don't know how hard is it how
many
i mean how many do they choose
how many well maybe twenty
two like that did you go on tour yeah oh
not even close there's like
i don't know four girls and four guys so
you were chosen at the four girls
out of probably thousands
yeah i don't know how many thousands
auditioned for april baby uh but did you
like her
um
not particularly really did you not talk
with her much no she was very uh
uh
she wasn't very outgoing right um she
didn't make much effort to to connect
though i i guess i also didn't i've
never been like a hey let's be friends
yeah yeah like so you feel like it was
partly your fault partly her fault
probably no well i think i mean you've
seen pictures where like she people fans
pay like 500 to take a picture with her
or something and they like have to be
like two feet away
you have you seen that only during the
pandemic
no i think this was not apparent no no
i'm saying pandemic i can understand two
feet away but um
wow and i just kind of remember thinking
like if you really like do not want to
be around people that much like and
don't want them touching you like
then don't offer photos ops you know
like where you're gonna be like give me
your money but don't touch me
um or maybe there's some who knows i
don't know like who am i to judge what
her reasonings are but that's just your
experience yeah she wasn't particularly
friendly um and there was her manager or
whoever it was at the time
there was like this just drama stuff and
they felt like we were leaking stuff to
the press about things and it was like
this is and
i didn't want to she didn't want me
another like blonde on stage that i
didn't want to dye my hair so i was like
in a wig and i just was like kind of on
i remember like looking at myself i'm on
tour and i'm you know back up dancing
after kind of more being in the front
and i'm in the back and they're like not
very nice and
i have this wig on and at one point i
got an eye infection
i was like my i had like my eye got
infected and i had like a sinus
infection and you're like on a tour bus
like this
you're dancing
yeah i had like and and it was like i
remember i had to wear like my glasses
because i had contacts and an eye
infection i couldn't and i couldn't not
have my glass like glasses on and so i
was on stage with like glasses and this
big wig and i just was like who am i i
don't even know like this is not me what
am i doing with my life
and and then i came back and that's when
i started taking acting classes and
um because of the bad experience you had
you felt like i want to do something
else well it just wasn't me anymore like
i wasn't this i've it's time for
something new and